new york i need you to get extra loud
for our future baby daddies machine gun
kelly and travis barker
yeah you heard that right our future
baby daddies megan fox and kourtney
kardashian just called their boyfriends
machine gun kelly and travis barker
their future baby daddies
i don't know if this is family friendly
y'all
it all went down at the 2021 mtv video
music awards in brooklyn when megan
court took the stage to introduce the
bloody valentine singer and the blink
182 drummer who were there to perform
mgk's new single paper cuts featuring
travis on the drums
i'm a huge fan of this next performer
i've watched him grow and not just as an
artist but also as a person
i'm a fan too and i think his drummer is
super hot
new york i need you to get extra loud
for our future baby daddies machine gun
kelly and travis parker
and the two close the show out with a
bang it was just magical their
performance including mgk's surprise
freestyle totally wowed the crowd and
the audience at home
[Music]
machine gun kelly who received his first
vma last year for best alternative video
was nominated in the same category this
year for my ex's best friend and one
machine gun kelly
featuring black bear
[Applause]
and in august mgk and travis got
matching tattoos to help announce the 31
year old singer's new album that's the
album title inked on their arms in black
dog
oh brother
travis previously produced machine gun
kelly's 2020 album tickets to my
downfall and will work on the musician's
upcoming lp but back to the vmas what a
way to bounce back before mgk's big win
and before he hit the stage with travis
he was snapped by photographers on the
red carpet seemingly getting into it
with mma fighter conor mcgregor
according to an eyewitness the two
exchanged some words before conor lunged
at him i don't know the man but when it
caught up with conor backstage he
insisted nothing happened i certainly
don't fight little vanilla his boy
rappers you know i don't even know the
guy i don't know anything about him
except that he's with megan fox you know
what i mean it didn't look like nothing
and word of the alleged incident spread
quick i heard there was a fight with
machine gun and and
uh conor mcgregor just over there about
two minutes ago so we were already off
to a good start
but mgk and megan didn't seem phased how
did you coordinate these outfits this
evening he was like you're going to be
naked tonight and i was like whatever
you say
daddy whatever daddy says eti caught up
with the love birds shortly after the
alleged altercation went down and megan
who starred in her man's music video for
bloody valentine couldn't help but gush
over the musician
are you proud of him very proud he's the
most talented boy in the world
and then you're pretty oh
pretty talented too seeing you and
bloody valentine are you guys going to
collaborate more when it comes to your
music videos in the future yeah he's not
allowed to have other hoes in his music
video
it's the queen or no one
[Music]
you